use a number line to compare 11.5 and
11.7 so let's draw a number line here
and I'm going to focus between 11 and 12
because that's where our two numbers are
sitting there 11 and then something else
some number of tenths so this right here
is 11 this right here would be 12 and
then let me draw the tenths so this
would be smack-dab in between so that
would be 11 and 5 tenths or that would
be 11.5 well I've already done the first
part I've figured out where 11.5 is it
smack dab in between 11 and 12 it's 11
and 5 tenths but let me find everything
else let me mark everything else on this
number line so that's 1/10 2/10 3/10
4/10 5/10 6/10 7/10 8/10 9/10 and then
10 tenths right on the 12 it's not
completely drawn to scale I'm hand
drawing it as good as I can so where is
eleven point seven going to be well this
is eleven point five this is eleven
point six this is eleven point seven 11
and seven tenths 1/10 2/10 3/10 4/10
5/10 6/10 7/10 this is 11 point seven
and the way we've drawn our lumber line
we are increasing as we go to the right
eleven point seven is to the right of
eleven point five it's clearly greater
than 11.5 11.7 is greater than eleven
point five and really seriously you
didn't have to draw a number line to
figure that out
they're both eleven and something else
this is 11 and 5/10 this is 11 and seven
tenths so clearly this one is going to
be greater you have both have 11 but
this has seven tenths as opposed to 5/10